you younger ones you make a new art
take what's available push it and
whether we like it or not we have to
deal with the new a new technology high
definition criminal experience is always
important you can make a film on the
camera the size of that doorknob and
still show it to 1600 people still a
great communal experience if you're
burning to say something no there's at
this point in time there's no more
excuses you can utilize an iPhone to
make a film in the 70s that decade we
were able to make pictures people
weren't talking about how much picture
was making primarily they were talking
about the new um these were films that
were like uh and I don't want to use it
because it could become a dirty word but
vision
a vision meaning that they have a way of
telling a story they can't tell you how
to make the movie
uh you have to have it in you you have
to have the inspiration the passion it's
all new you just break it open break
open the form don't just uh just you
know have your tripod and a camera
that's standing on it don't pay
attention industry Do Your Own Thing